[MUSIC PLAYING]
MOE SY: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining the Google
for Games Developer Summit.
My name is Mo.
I am a cloud gaming
architect at Google Cloud.
Today I will be joined
by Christina and Jason
from Unity to talk about
Unity Game Simulation.
If you're a game
developer, you probably
know Unity, the leading
real-time 3D development
engine that supports over
25 platforms and powers 50%
of all new games.
What you might not know
is Unity and Google Cloud
have partnered for years to
make game development easier
and more accessible
for more creators using
the power of the cloud.
Last fall, Unity announced
a Unity Simulation,
a new cloud-based product that
enables designers, developers,
and creators to generate
synthetic training
data at scale, as
well as test, train,
and validate all their computer
vision and perception projects
in Unity by harnessing
the power of the cloud.
Within Google Cloud, Unity
leverages Google's turnkey
Kubernetes solution, GKE.
GKE, or Google
Kubernetes Engine,
gives Unity developers
a secure way
to manage and operate
simulations at scale.
GKE provides strong
security defaults,
such as encryption at rest,
encryption in transit,
leading to a more secure
environment for Unity
developers.
As an added benefit
of running GKE,
Unity is able to seamlessly
integrate with GCP's ecosystem.
Unity uses Google's
virtual private cloud
to define its global network,
as well as Google Cloud Identity
and Access Management to manage
fine-grained access control,
each of which have first-class
integrations within GKE.
Today, we're excited to
help our friends at Unity
announce their latest
innovative product
in the world of simulation
that's specifically
tailored for game developers.
I would like to introduce
Christina from Unity
to talk about Unity
Game Simulation.
CHRISTINA GUO: Thanks, Mo.
Creating games is hard, and
launching a quality game
is even harder.
Yet the first impression your
game makes on your players
can determine its
long-term success.
To build a quality game, you
need to thoroughly balance it
prior to launch.
A well-balanced game will
create a fun experience
for all your players.
You'll appeal to
more players and keep
them happy and engaged, which
means a higher lifetime value.
So how do you create
a well-balanced game?
Currently, the answer is
extensive manual balancing.
Through spreadsheets
and human playtesters,
you'll tediously try to find the
right damage value for a weapon
or the ideal speed
of a character.
But these are just two of
hundreds of possible parameters
that you might want to
adjust in your game.
In order to get
these right, you may
need to spend hours
tweaking values
in oversimplified and
inaccurate spreadsheets.
Or you contract dozens
of human playtesters,
but the feedback you receive
is subjective and costly.
Today, we're excited
to announce Unity Game
Simulation, supported by the
Google Cloud infrastructure.
Unity Game Simulation is
an affordable solution
that complements
your pre-launch play
tests to provide faster
iteration and results at scale.
The tool allows you to balance
more and iterate on your game
more often.
Using the online dashboard,
you have the power
to setup, run, and analyze
thousands of simulations.
Because these
player interactions
run simultaneously, you also
speed up your balancing.
The scale of cloud balancing
provides more accurate results
than manual balancing
and spreadsheets
[? can ?] replicate.
This quantitative
balancing coverage
costs a fraction of a
playtester's hourly rate,
giving them more time
to focus on the look
and feel of the game.
Let's dive into an example.
Furyion Games, a Canadian
game development studio,
created "Death Carnival," a
fast-paced top-down shooter.
One of the features of the game
is the weapon socket system.
Each weapon allows players to
select a base weapon, ammo,
weapon module, and
temporary power-ups.
Each of these
combinations is made up
of many variables that
control the play style
and efficiency of the web.
In earlier versions
of the game, the team
balanced weapons by hand.
They would configure a
weapon, compile a build,
send it out to playtesters,
and watch them play.
Based on the feedback, they
would reconfigure the weapons
and repeat.
Each iteration of this
process would take hours.
Enter Unity Game Simulation.
Furyion used the tool to run
thousands of simulations.
They were able to identify
the right combinations of base
weapons, ammo, weapon
modules, and power-ups
for their desired survivability
and level completion time.
This allowed them to ensure
the weapons were balanced.
By configuring the weapon
parameters and multi-stage
simulations, Furyion
was able to condense
the equivalent of 165
million playthroughs
into just 10
efficient simulations,
taking just over three days to
balance their weapons system.
They estimate that the tool
saved them $80,000 and 600
hours of dev time.
Those resources
would just previously
have been spent on managing
playtesters, measuring
weapon performance,
and compiling builds.
Now, they can instead
be spent on polishing
the creative
elements of the game.
Jason, an engineer
on the team, will now
demonstrate how Furyion
achieved these results.
JASON GRECO: After deciding
to use Game Simulation,
a game developer at
Furyion implements
the Unity Game Simulation
package and uploads
a build to the game simulation
service from the editor window.
I won't go through
this in detail,
but the process is simple.
Once the developer has
uploaded the "Death Carnival"
simulation build, it's
time to create a simulation
from the web UI.
This is where designers
configure and run simulations.
For this "Death
Carnival" simulation,
we will be testing 45 key
combinations of weapons, ammo,
and modules 100
times each in order
to establish the mean
performance of each combination
with high confidence.
Let's name this build Phase 1.
And we'll select our
build from the dropdown.
For the values in
our simulation,
we'll be testing shotgun,
machine gun, and missile.
Our ammo count will be
10, 15, 20, 25, and 30.
And for our weapon module,
we'll be using triple
shot, wave, and burst.
Once this simulation
is finished,
we'll get a spreadsheet with
a row for each combination
of these parameter values.
And lastly, we'll run each
combination 100 times.
So in total, this will run 4,500
combinations of simulations.
So fast forward one
hour, and we can
see that this simulation
has already completed,
and we have our aggregate data.
So let's open up this data.
I've gone ahead and imported
the file into Google Sheets
and made a chart with
the level completion time
by weapon combination.
So here we can see the chart.
And in this chart, we see
the shotgun and machine
gun both have some pretty
underpowered combinations.
As a next step, I can
buff these combinations
and run the
simulation once more.
Furyion has already
done this, so let's take
a look at the final results.
And we can see that the
underpowered combinations have
come down pretty drastically in
player completion time, which
translates to a much better
gameplay experience for "Death
Carnival's" players.
Now that we've seen Unity
Game Simulation in action,
let's peel back the
onion a bit and talk
about the underlying
infrastructure.
We chose GKE to build
Unity Game Simulation
on top of because it
gives us the container
management we wanted.
With Google Compute
Engine, we would
have needed to manage the
components individually,
such as auto scaling,
networking, security,
container health, et cetera.
With GKE, we just
specify what we want,
and it's managed for us.
One of the most important
features in building Unity Game
Simulation is
GKE's auto scaling.
We need the ability to
dynamically scale up
our number of resources
so we can quickly
handle workloads of
thousands of simulations
without having to pay
for idle resources.
Because games all have
different system requirements,
using separate node pools, we're
able to adjust this instance
type for each game when
we schedule a simulation.
With Unity Game
Simulation, users
tend to run a mix of smaller and
larger batches of simulations,
so it's important for us to
have fast scaling of resources.
The smaller number of
simulations a user is running,
the more impactful
any extra overhead is,
so being able to quickly
scale up as needed
lets us handle both
types of workloads.
In addition to GKE, we used a
number of other GCP offerings
in building this tool.
One example is Stackdriver,
which we used for our services.
The log aggregation and
metric instrumentation
around GKE and other
Google Cloud resources
helped minimize the work in
setting up our dashboards
and alerting as we transition
from our initial proof
of concept into a
production system.
Because we're running user
code, it's also important for us
to sandbox everything
as much as possible.
With IAM and RBAC, the
user code containers
can be configured to
run with no permissions
to any GKE or GCP resources,
even on the same node.
IAM also helps secure
our resources and data
by locking them down to
just a few necessary admins
for a services so we're
able to create a service
account for each of them
with the minimum required
permissions.
In addition to GKE and other
products we just mentioned,
I'd like to quickly cover
some of the other tools
that we found very useful in
the development of Unity Game
Simulation.
First is Cloud SQL,
which we're using
as the database for services
that manage our job state
and orchestration.
Second is GCR, which we're using
along with IAM that I mentioned
earlier for securely managing
all of our Docker containers.
We also use Dataproc
for handling
the aggregation of
our simulation data
from each of the individual
simulation instances.
And finally, Terraform,
which helps us
manage all the GCP
infrastructure that we have.
In summary, Unity
Game Simulation
creates a more efficient,
accurate, and affordable
solution for game balancing.
It complements playtesting,
backing human feedback
with quantitative data.
Try the open beta for free.
Visit unity.com/products/game
simulation for more
information, and thank
you all for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]